and frankie montage trying to pick up a
victory in the first game of this series
against the very tough boston red sox
frankie
coming off a start against the san
francisco giants one start against
the red sox so frankie do to get on a
nice roll let's hope tonight is the
beginning of that kiki hernandez has hit
a lead off home run for the red sox
in three of their last five games so of
course he is in the lead off spot again
swung on a high
pop-up third base side playable foul
territory
chapman is right there drifting with it
back into fair territory and he makes
the catch and that's the way our ball
game begins
and that'll bring up verdugo the
ex-dodger is batting at 280.
swung on a five-ball angle down the
left-field line long run for camp
crossing the foul line
right near the side wall leaping makes
an incredible
catch what a play by tony kemp
racing and crossing the foul line deep
in the left field corner
leaping right up against that tall side
wall
and pulls it in what a play well that's
an early entry into the
what will tony kemp do tonight and it
brings up xander bogarts
swung on him and with great help from
tony kemp frankie montage works at one
two three top of the first ia saw this
gentleman earlier in the season juarez
rodriguez making his
16th start of the season with a record
of six and four he's had numerous starts
against the athletics
ramon loriano is going to be in the
lead-off spot this is rolled left side
bogart's gobbles one away
as loriano couldn't leg it out so here's
elvis who's bounding 227
one two that is strike three calls
a backwards k for eduardo rodriguez
got two outs here and it brings up matt
olsen that's taken
just slowing outside tomatoes have their
first base runner and that'll bring up
chapman
one then a ground ball to third
backhanded there by marwyn gonzalez his
side on flip to first retires the side
now brings up hunter renfro probably
he's one of the best free agent signings
of anybody this past off season hunter
renfrew and this one's hit towards cena
lorianno's back gloria at the wall and
he's got just enough room to
jump up and make the catch and renfro
gives it a ride he's out number two
here's the veteran morrowind gonzalez a
switch hitter batting left
swung on him yes got him with a split
montage starts the game by retiring
sixth straight this is something the a's
were not very good at in their series
against the rangers they were combined
one for 20 with runners in scoring
position frank schwendell batting
1-1 rolled left side bogarts
knocked it down pender has to stop at
third
what a play bogart saved a run with a
terrific play it's going to be a hit for
swindell
but obviously if it gets by him it's a
run for the ace still a chance to escape
as tony kemp comes to the plate
strike three calls eduardo pitches
nicely around and air is third punch out
no hit rally a hit batter and a walk and
here comes verdugo
bouncing ball weekly hit on the right
side lowry has it on to first base
and frankie montage dodges a bullet in
the third lead off base on balls here in
the fourth
so here is raffy the other left side
all-star for the red sox
swing and a little blooper down the left
field line and that is gonna fall in for
a hit
and kept dives it gets past him bogart's
heads for third he's gonna
score total misplay by tony kemp
it's an rbi double and the red sox lead
two down devers to third as christian
vasquez
climbs in bouncing ball to third coming
in for it is chapman gloves throws on
the run in time
and the enemy is over the red sox get
one and eduardo rodriguez going back to
work
after he had a nine pitch third inning
here's jed lowry
100 pitch is grounded to the left side
could be two the second for one over the
first
double play beauty that ends that ends
the inning the first two have reached
here for the sox in the fifth this is
the part of game that frankie
ground ball outs three in each last two
winnings and he'd love one here to
see if he could get two with qp
amendments
olson's got it fires nice throw to alba
sanders back to the first a double oh
my incredible i didn't think there was
any chance they could turn two there
and that is a dazzling three six
three double play two down man at third
here's verdugo
2-1 grounded and that is
down the line and it scores santana
verdugo comes through this time and the
socks out on in the fifth
jb wendelkin takes over here in the six
with a
huge out to get michael chavis and the
bases
loaded with two outs back at the plate
murphy's got to play
coming toward the red sox dugout he
makes the catch
one pitch and when delkin puts out the
fire in the sixth eduardo rodriguez who
has thrown five innings of one hit ball
two down and here is matt olson he got
him with a cutter
swung on and missed and eddie rodriguez
appears to be back
six strikeouts through six [ __ ]
hernandez starts things off
and he drives him
[Applause]
into the corner goes tony kemp and he
tracked it down
here comes bogarts to the plate
basketball hit high in the air behind
first
racing toward foul ground here comes
pinder and he's going to
make a sliding grab inside the red sox
bullpen
a lot of great leather thrown around by
the a's in the top of the seventh
now jed lowry hitless in two tries right
field and deep
red throw back renfro at the wall turns
around
and that baby is gone jed lowry
gets the a's off the deck the groud is
alive and the a's are down 2-1
and now it's 31-year-old matt barnes the
closer for the red sox and he's having
an all-star type season folks
the veteran elvis to try anything he can
possibly do to get on base
and give dies a spark in the spot over
the knife swung on a drive to deep
center field
going back hernandez at the track right
to the wall
elvis ambrose with his first home run as
an athletic
he ties the game in the bottom of the
knife a's
two red sox two how do you like that
and michael chavis begins the tenth
inning as
the automatic base runner at second [ __ ]
hernandez the batter
first pitch swinging and it dumps in
past
lowry they wave chavis around
and the red sox lead the a's have the
tying and winning runs aboard
sean murphy comes to the plate in the
center
hernandez lines it up brown to the plate
the throw
he got him excellent throw oh
what a dart from [ __ ] beautiful thing
they stay ahead three to two two
outs and here's schwendell at the plate
and he locks this to left
vertugo's under it and the red sox win
it in extras